SImilarly, let's go through some commands that you can run on
remote repositories. First command is the command to copy a repository,
which is git clone in which you get a remote repository and you make a lot of
copy in your working directory. The repository can be specified as a URL.
It can be a local file, it can be specified using the HTTP or
the SSH protocol, and there's also other ways to do it.
This creates a complete local copy of the repository, as it says, and links it
to the remote repository, which is what is called the origin. And if you want,
you could also actually link to the repository, later. Then the normal way of
receiving changes from a repository is to perform a git pull command. And we saw
that you can also perform the same operation through two commands, get fetch and
git merge. In case you want to inspect the changes before actually merging them,
before actually getting them in your local copy. And
if you want to send changes that you have in your local repository to
a remote repository, you will use the git push command.